sa virginité
sa virgile saghir qui
a perdu un candidat
[Musique]
je commence à avoir beaucoup de mal avec
lui j'aimais bien et puis essayer dé
tous en train de tout [ __ ] en l'air se
fout ça cher peuple berioui que va
perdre cyril hanouna en 2022 maintenant
qu'il est célibataire
[Applaudissements]
la famille mes amis qu'est-ce que cyril
ne leur a jamais à personne sa virginité
qu'est-ce que hervé a perdu hier dans
l'amour est dans le pré
mais de premier league
hier soir m6 a diffusé un nouvel épisode
de l'amour est dans le lot l'aventuré se
poursuit pour les agréent qu est parvenu
à les berner le beurre 2 kg passe de 43
[Rires]
rbds et ça prend quand stéphanie ont
donné les détails de cette première
bille puisque c'était le grand jour pour
lui il a enfin perdu sa vie alors il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont réagi il a dit
il ya des gens qui ont des idées
l'émission était trop voyeuriste c'était
qu'ils ont donné trop de détails moi je
me suis régalé j'ai pas aujourd'hui en
finale extrait c'est l'extrait télé la
saison pour moi pour le même
s'ils n'étaient plus là car je n'aime
pas ses agresseurs oui mais oui et non
oui regardez
je me sens très bien je suis heureuse on
a passé une belle mine oui quoi dire que
c'était intense où je m'attendais cox à
aller aussi vite grâce est vrai qu'il
m'a dit je suis prêt je crois que j'ai
été j'étais très bon
ça va être rapide mais non pas du tout
c'est pas du tout déception banon
[Musique]
je les suive annoncé cambrai donc en
plus jour
[Musique]
mais allumer la lumière voilà quoi je
trouvais pas le foot on
dit
c'est pas possible on dit mais cite
pourtant dit que cette façon
[Musique]
est-ce que cet extrait vous a choqué
pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi qui ne
connaissait pas hervé vous a préparé un
petit récap déjà du parcours dernier on
vous explique tout ça après bien entendu
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont été
choqués par
cette année dans l'amour est dans le pré
il ya une star et crv 43 ans qui n'a
encore jamais vécu la moindre nuit
caliente avec une femme 20 mai dernier
une fille grâce à l'émission il a donc
pu rencontrer vanessa et stéphanie et
surtout enfin présenté des meufs à sa
mère qui n'y croyaient plus
même si bon après on n'a pas eu trop
l'impression qu'elle soit tombée sous le
charme la mama elles sont pas allés à
son
nom mal aux pêcheurs hervé a donc mis
les petits plats dans les grands à base
de balades en voiture en quoi nous mêmes
en bateau détresse via la bête mais bon
il ya eu quelques tensions entre vanessa
et stéphanie j'ai envie de passer du
temps avec harvey bien sûr explique van
ly ça elles partent au plus vite quand
la cette balade c'était bien sauf que
bon vanessa elle était là quoi donc
hervé il a dû faire son choix et il a
des cheveux nsa
il reste avec stéphanie et se rapproche
du but final plein dedans ça bouillonne
ça bouillonne et il a bien réussi à la
galoche la semaine dernière
[Musique]
géraldine maillet alors je n'aimais pas
l'amour dans le pré puis j'ai aimer
l'amour est dans le pré et je déteste à
nouveau l'amour est dans le pré alors
c'est pas la faute évidemment des
agriculteurs et en particulier de hervé
de stéphanie qui sont mais adorable
extrêmement machado sauf que ce sont des
rats de laboratoire
j'ai trouvé la séquence hier absolument
obscène plein de voyeurisme c'est quoi
la prochaine étape en fait on met une
caméra dans la chambre mais
la taille zizi on essaie de savoir si
elle a eu un orgasme il a joui à partir
de combien de minutes non franchement on
les instrumentalise et je trouve que
c'est ignoble pour eux parce qu'en fait
on regarde ça me regarde ça avec un peu
un peu de moqueries je vois bien le
public on n'a pas beaucoup d'empathie
pour les regarder mais non d'accord mais
je suis désolé alors le public est
comme ça
alors me et que je sais qu'il qui aime
l'amour et autres vraiment là je ne
comprends pas on est on les a regardés
moi je les ai regardés avec beaucoup de
tendresse tu voyais qu'elle était
tellement heureux lui ni gollito savoir
ça a duré longtemps et
on les utilise le marchand qui ont fait
des tonnes au m'énerve c'est
insupportable
et orgasme et juste après aussi pour
montrer que c'était super mignon pauvre
hervé quoi tant mieux s'il a trouvé
l'amour mais je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse de les utiliser comme ça
mais c'est nous qui lui millions là
en mettant douteux et sa spontanéité
c'est à dire en prison elle remet en
doute nom est celle de l'émission je
suis arrivé parce que quand il va se
voir il me dire ah bon j'ai été
tellement unique ça mais non mais t'as
pas été humilié c'était formidable
touchant sur mon nom inscrit au théâtre
il ya 40 ans tu sois plus vierge et
qu'il le dise avec beaucoup de joie
d'être mentalement moi je suis d'accord
avec mamie nous parce que géraldine ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que tu penses
que ce garçon est débile et produit au
gdc formidable et qu'il avait utilisé
comme responsable
je pense que les gens ne sont pas bêtes
discussion ils ont envie de s'exprimer
sur un moment qui sont passés enfin je
veux dire il est pas il n'est pas naïf
il n'est pas bête donc s'y exprimer
c'est un truc qu'il a à dos les vergers
pour la première fois il avait envie de
montrer son bonheur à la caméra mais
c'est pas imbécile mais j'ai pas dis
d'ailleurs servir du
programme j'ai toujours dit qu'on se
moquait à leurs dépens ces agriculteurs
trouve ça déplorable excusé mais mille
façons de le faire différemment oui tu
racontes par sadok sassi
non mais c'est le franchement je trouve
ça extrêmement gênant on regarde
regarde d agréer
souvent l'aise j'ai vu le dire d arrêter
là c'est pire qu'au début de l'hiver les
ppri la danse a du mal à s'exprimer
c'est pas mal mais je n'ai jamais aimé
cette émission et je la trouve de pire
en pire voilà j'aime heavy metal
on va regarder ce qui s'est passé le
soir d'après pour hervé stéphane et on
va pas se mentir un v il était très
excité à l'idée de passer sa deuxième
nuit d'amour avec sa prétendante il
avait clairement at il ne s'en cachait
pas du tout il était excité comme ça
c'est normal et évident mais on va lui
d'ailleurs
il pas de la vie s'appelle la mémoire
rappelle le désire mais oui ça paye
carte noire café nommé désir
moneo soir tombait même doit pas manger
comme amina est ce que tu veux faire
c'est fera pas
de manger beaucoup mais après il faut
sera le dépenser aussi j'ai ça en
débarrasser la vaisselle heures oui non
mais ça va pas faire assez c'est pas
grave on s'en fout
on ainsi pas que ces gens qui se
couchent et aller voilà bon
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya des moments un petit peu chaud
alors bien gentil mais non seulement ça
arrive un chiot non seulement ses
ouailles au rythme en plus l'émission
elle tombe de plus en plus dans les
travers de la télé réalité trash moi
j'ai jamais vu un casting aussi cliché à
traîner comme ça bah non mais de nous
raconter des ébats sexuels comme ça ça
c'est que le début l'extrait de son ex
mari voilà et je trouve ça tient l'autre
excès dont il parlait et je trouve que
comme pour la fédérale 1 les candidats
comprennent de plus en plus ce qu'on
attend bien et donc l'émission à elle
perd en authenticité et ces domaines on
peut pas d'un côté dire qu'il est naïf
et de larmes l'utilisent et de l'autre
produit a fait ce qu'on veut c'est
la fraude est rock les mots de la mort
que hervé il est vierge
a dit mais c'est génial ça
fait de la télévision mobile a pesé dans
sa décision
qui vont s'accrocher aux yeux des
spectateurs c'est un profil
perso c'est pour ce genre de moment que
je regarde ses amis sont là vous êtes
qui jean michel maire merci ça me fait
très plaisir de vous revoir ses droits
civiques en tout cas très élégant c'est
gentil moi c'est pour ce genre de moment
je regarde cette émission là aussi au
delà parce que voilà c'est des moments
croustillants moi j'ai pas trouvé qu'on
se foutait de la gueule agriculteurs ont
montré en panne j'ai son bonheur
benjamin jeu content pour toi quand tu
essaies les matières duquesne que les
deux jours il a tenu quarante trois en
deuxième
on a pas besoin d'infos sur benoît
cassagne
l'odyssée prix de base il était
tranquille wayana et teko basse
le gars il est en nette hausse était
comment tu prends une bonne
léché en plus dans l'amour est dans le
pré ya toujours des moments assez chaud
est-ce que vous rappelez en 2019 lors de
la 14e saison de l'amour est dans le pré
de candidats nous ont offert l'un des
moments les plus romantiques de
l'histoire avec un roulage de pelle
mémorable oui je me rappelle à la
violence
avait de la gueule
[Musique]
laval
c'est pour ça qu'on est là
c'est pour ça que j'aime le moins
d'après brice leverdez avait été choqué
très choqué il était partout au gilet
daily show qui lui sont extrêmement
choqués laissez moi finir comment c'est
pas avec votre petit rire je tente de
gloussements là
c'est devenu une émission érotique
c'est une télé réalité et entier
à l'érotisme avec fatou pas venir nous
sommes en vacances des enfants regardent
alors on voit des gens qui perdent leur
virginité mais la prochaine fois ce sera
quoi donner des leçons n'irait la
dérange avec absolument pas avec amour
tout est joué tout et c'est hyper sympa
mais ça ne sera ce qu'ils ont dit oui
mais aujourd'hui tu fais c'est tendance
et sincère
ce sont des acteurs
semaine dernière ils étaient en train de
s'embrasser de tueries me vire je
trouvais ça laisse les noms c'est
l'équipe et non si on veut laisser
parler les autres il garder ces mots
vous avez soulevé rien dire
gfr angoissant que dire des conneries
comme les nuits c'est vrai mais vraie
équipe et gilles verdez pour douter de
leur sont unis canada mais il paie de
superbes et sinon bah oui c'est oui je
vais reconnu comme alger pourquoi pas ce
que vous dites mais je sais pas pourquoi
tu tues j'ai compris pas d'ouvrir
monsieur c'est dommage qu'on est
toujours intéressant non mais sauf que j
tu dis n'importe quoi et pourtant
j'étais d'accord avec toi au départ oui
mais je ne pas décrédibiliser les
puissants parce que m et stéphanie sont
ordinairement sincère c'est une très
belle histoire sauf que moi je n'ai pas
je trouve que enfin non mais c'est comme
quand on sourit de bassar n'empêche
cette séquence où gilles verdez voulait
mettre des millions de gens aux chambres
et que je
ne regarde pas les téléspectateurs c'est
quelque chose d'un team c'est sa part de
priver après quelque chose qu'on doit
pas partager comme ça ne doit pas y
avoir des caméras intrusive on n'a pas
compté ses ébats on doit pas dire à jean
louis borloo
on est entré l'image qui a marqué tout
le monde lors de la saison 15 en 2020
c'est celle de jean claude qui chute en
voulant rentrer dans son jean louis
assis près car cocu par terre drôle au
maire de pernes en mai chez mme lagarde
sait comment
les médias plus de poids lourds est
comment
âmes sensibles s'abstenir minuit vient
de sonner et l'heure est venue pour jc
d'exhiber à yolande à sa parade nuptiale
à poil
[Musique]
sciemment dévié libre
plutôt non
[Rires]
je sais les gens qui arrivent
ça s'appelle une arrêt sur image un
réseau
[Applaudissements]
il a dit
ça y est la même on est connecté vous
êtes là l'humour ça fait plaisir
c'était très drôle enjouée et le plus
bas mais l'arrivée ça ne choque personne
là c'est non parce que c'est spontané
tout à l'heure si on a vu tout est faux
quand il sent
la fenêtre mais la prod leur demande
embrassez vos narines et de fermer les
rideaux fait comme si vous allez vous
coucher quitté faux ils ont fait un
montage final et c'est vrai ils ont fait
un montage où elle raconte sa nuit c'est
sa première fois est cuit et autres ils
ont entrecoupé sa de rire du mec qui
sont complètement valable en connaissait
pas là
s'est tourné de sorte à ce qu'on
comprenne que s'étaient tournés en fait
exprès tu vois l'essor de la fenêtre où
ils font ça c'est fou non contre mais on
sait que c'est fou non mais c'est pas
ça net comme ça c'est vrai
en scène mais cette s'affiche comédiens
ici bisous ya pas
arrêté on va avoir c'est extra aussi de
gironde le maraîcher et sa prétendante
lucile après le speed dating giro m'a
invité lucile dans le son exploitation
et très vite le couple va conclure ça
aussi c'était une des images chaudes
dans l'amour est dans le pré regardez ça
a été très très vite on n'a même pas eu
le temps de dire on
est bien en vie la deux
ça fait longtemps que ce n'était pas
arrivé donc courte mais intense
je garde pour moi papa confus bien dormi
papa quant à nous dire
un peu court mais intense
[Applaudissements]
mais si il le gardait pour juger au
trias envie de le dire sinon tu m as du
talent et du niger
mais
dès qu'ils voient dès qu'on parle de zz
ça s'énerve est en train de décider ce
que les gens ont le droit de ne pas s'il
lui ont dû le garder pour lui le gars
nous si l'autre a envie de le donner la
star 6 attendant gaza il était pas bien
vous attendent bah oui ils attendent un
bébé et hydro
exploitation ils ont une vie couple très
harmonieux mais hervé hervé et et puceau
imaginer que ce soit une fille est ce
que vous auriez dit pareil quand
j'aurais dit non à
l'argent sûr
vous aurez des mets mon dieu une fille
pertes habilité à la télévision mais non
bah ça c'est le pissot de service et on
en manque de nuit insupportable souhaité
le dire j'arrête
à pau non mais qu'est ce que t'en sais
il te dit que tu m'a
rattrapé non mais sérieux on peut pas
dire n'importe
quel intérêt la belgique était ridicule
si tu es ridicule tétouan ce soit du
ridicule de bout en bout
vraiment bêtes y regarder les pensions
en janvier s'était ni dans les portes en
janvier qu'on va passer à table et
chaises
[Rires]
non non mais c'est vrai que c'est un
bruit de fond tout cas ça a énormément
choqué je vous prie sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya eu énormément de tweets
voilà les draps non plus sans doute
placez-vous une limite entre l'intimé
l'intimité c'était hyper genot de mieux
en mieux et autres cartons on va savoir
les positions aussi lors du décès de la
pudeur de stéphane et hervé 21h16 entre
le récit détaillé de leurs coït avec
ledit qui tape l'armoire et la séance de
eric de déchirage de photos stéphanie
armés nous ont offert de superbes
séquences pour ma lester b voilà ce
devant les relais quand même là bien sûr
ils étaient 4 millions ça a très bien
marché mais c'est vrai que mais voilà il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui ont été
choqués par cette époque mais c'est à
dire ciel macharis les fanico chopinot
excellent à prendre c'est vrai qu'ils
arrivent et stéphanie voilà vous n'avez
pas donné votre avis maintenant moi il
peut demander moi je vois jouer mais
faudrait il faudrait quand même je pense
vraiment que c'est votre dernière
je le pense vraiment je crois qu'il faut
un peu de bienveillance de la
bienveillance était charmant ils sont
très touchants ils sont timides ces deux
timides qui s'affrontent comme ça c'est
compliqué pour eux certes il en fait
devant les caméras peut-être que ça les
a aidés de le faire devant les caméras
sur dans voilà bravo il est pourvu que
ça dure non j'ai fait je suis en fait de
servir
vous ne servez à rien ne sert à rien ces
âmes en résumé elle sert à rien c'est un
bon résumé gilles verdez donner votre
avis c'est une catastrophe toi tu toi
mais voilà
les deux habitent la réponse est une
fuite et que
afrique contre quoi luttent isabelle le
vif
[Applaudissements]
je me demandais
d'avoir un goût la réponse
nous c'est une histoire bon danse avec
les stars
ah oui ça avec escales canon bah oui
qu'arrive-t-il à welch denver
est encore jeune oui oui oui les mâles à
cause de quoi ou hd la production sont
ils fâchés non nous fait une fuite oui
je prends qu'a dévoilé youtuber des
coulisses de ang lee jane et son ancien
on a beaucoup parlé dans l'émission wade
n ya eu quelques petites différences et
bien lui je voudrais surtout depuis son
élimination de d'als le blogueur aqua
bay a diffusé un audio du témoignage
d'un membre de la production de
l'émission ça balance sec et moi je vais
vous dire je trouve que le danseur on a
très mal par la mauritanie je suis
choquée moi j'ai d'autres éléments à
vous avez d'autres éléments ouais j'ai
des éléments de l'enquète del'enquête
absolument j'ai enquêté regardez
[Musique]
alors qu il y a deux semaines ou hdmi
qui telle aventure danse avec les stars
très vite de nombreuses rumeurs sur une
mauvaise entente avec la production
avait fuité comment ça il faut dire que
la jeune chanteuse avait enchaîné les
indices car en plus de ne pas participer
à l'after de l'émission officiellement
pour des raisons juridiques la jeune
femme n'avait que très peu commenté les
rumeurs autour de son départ
mais comme nous vous l'avions révélé
dans tpm paix ce serait bien une guerre
entre ou et jane et son danseur samuel
texier qui soit la cause de la
mésentente entre la jeune femme et la
chaîne est peut-être la cause de son
départ
[Musique]
en effet selon le blogueur aquabelles
une violente dispute aurait éclaté entre
la chanteuse et son partenaire de danse
ce dernier aurait littéralement pété les
plombs face au comportement
insupportable de la jeune femme comme
leur est confié un membre de la
production aux blogueurs on était en
répétition sur le plateau et son danseur
qui est quelqu'un de très simple réservé
et gentil a pété un câble et lui a dit
ce que tout le monde pensait selon lui
ce annuel de techci aurait déclaré à
welch dnt une chieuse tu es une
emmerdeuse tu crois que tu es arrivé
mais rappelle toi que tu as 17 ans et ça
peut s'arrêter du jour au lendemain il
va falloir que tu commences à respecter
les gens avec qui tu travailles une
nouvelle révélation qui ne devrait pas
arranger les rumeurs autour des tensions
dans l'émission
alors moi je moi je connais pas dans
l'ouest donne toujours vous le savez
ouais enfin si elle s'est mal comporté
j'ai pas mal
c'est une star on a parlé comme ça mais
c'est
la palme allemand la personne j'ai des
infos à la mal par la percée mais j'ai
des enfants mais le kin one way
oui je sais les mêmes infos vous voilà
ce qui s'est passé en fait la production
voulait que wheldon pas vous savez que
tout est organisé dans danse avec les
stars et ils ont mis ou sdn en condition
de partir et ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le danseur ourdi par la produit
pour 10
mai mécanisée vu sa production a été
honteux avec wes des miss à le danseur
way nourdine
ils ont ils ont tout fait pour que wes
dnssec les flancs elle a réussi à pas
pété les plombs mais wade n heureusement
pour elle à un entourage formidable
avons franchement bravo à l'entourage de
ben voila et son entourage a dit arrêtez
bassin ta voix soul et elle est très
jeune elle va craquer non mais c'est
vrai il faut 4 simon marty
exactement je suis vraiment je vous dit
notamment qu'il est là tranquille et
sans lui on les adore moi formons une
famille mais je suis désolé mais dans
das un lanceur n'a pas à parler comme ça
une personne n'est là pour mettre en
valeur leur bourbier où là et si c'est
le cas c'est extrêmement grave parce que
ça nul à trévise et pendant la
compétition
construction gagner d'un regard serment
mais c'est pas parce que tu peux ne pas
être d'accord avec les câbles pas bien
sûr ça puisqu'on aime quoi lui dire être
à 17 ans sont là pour se mettre des
cévennes à voir avec ça il a pas mal lui
parler exactement l allure pas mal parlé
en six ans ils sont là pour les mettre
en valeur les aider et en plus tous ceux
qui ont gagné danse avec les stars il
avait une très grande complicité que
leurs danseurs donc ça l'a fortement
handicapé dans la compétition et si les
tories ne sont pas parce qu'elle est pas
populaire elle est extrêmement pas bien
sûr c'est parce que ces prestations
étaient légèrement en dessous tu es nul
et on imagine que c'est à cause de ça du
coup à la merci moi je suis écoeuré par
cette affaire chad lowe d'arrêter la
danse n'est pas du tout ça c'est quoi
bon avoir assuré moins chaud à deux
doigts d'arrêter la danse des signes
le casting samuel texier a été choisi
parce qu'il est jeune c'est un jeune
danseur il n'est pas connue encore comme
la jeune danseuse qui l'ont mis avec
michou et donc ils ont voulu faire des
associations ce salon il n'allait pas
mettre un un danseur plus âgé de 30 ans
38 us
c'est justement pour emballage et 1900
très à l'aise la dernière semaine elle
n'est pas venue aux répétitions elle la
plante est systématiquement donc du coup
le répéter mais non mais ça l'année
où personne ne fait ça on est super
réglo mais l'ensemble avec maryse et
l'écart n'a en outre le fait qu'elle n'a
pas été respecté coiffeur maquilleur
contrairement à pamela anderson à
l'arrêt croix ou maladroit mais je veux
dire ça va bon c'est vrai je dirais oui
mais je me demande si elle est justement
il faut les reprendre peut-être
certainement western et donc en tout cas
samuel textile il aurait été exemplaires
soit chez moi je gère t aurais je louais
je donne ici on a fait un tournage
ensemble allers venues à l'heure elle
était elle a alors fait si on vous voit
le tour maria elle était extraordinaire
rien ne la sent impuissant cédant
nouvelle chaîne des terrils et pas
n'importe quoi ça m'a texté c'est sony
qui a fait les magasins texte
dur avec le physiothérapeute
je la défendrai jusqu'à ma mort ok
jusqu'à ma mort si vous aussi une amie
juste au moment même si c'est votre ami
quand une amie veut quelque chose alors
en coton l'union et la grosse tête du
bout on lui prête une réputation n'a pas